foreign
Hills dotted with countless grapevines
and hundreds of wineries California's
Napa Valley is considered to be the
heart of America's wine industry but
that wasn't always the case 2022 marks
50 years since the unofficial coming out
party for Napa's winemakers on the world
stage John Blackstone has more on what's
become known as the class of 1972.
[Music]
[Applause]
Napa's Silver Oak Winery celebrated its
50th anniversary with the release of its
latest vintage and nearly hundred dollar
a bottle Cabernet Sauvignon Silver Oak
has come a long way in the 50 years
since Vines were first planted here by
David Duncan's father this was dairy
farm it was pasture land for dairy cows
there were fruit orchards there were
almond trees it was a completely
different environment here you know back
then American Oak barrels Duncan now
Silver Oak CEO says his father Ray was
not a winemaker he was a businessman who
saw a business opportunity he actually
read a report that I believe was
published in 1970 by Bank of America
that said wine drinking in the U.S was
going to increase from a half a gallon
per person per year so mind you that's
like two bottles of wine to five gallons
per person per year and dad said wow
that sounds like a neat growth business
in 1972 your father wasn't alone in
seeing the potential for the Napa Valley
yes there's the class of 72 as they call
us which we're part of a lot of Winery
started 1972 like on the order of 24.
wow yeah and nap and Sonoma because it
looked like a good investment it did
look like a good investment Bo Barrett
is CEO of Shadow Montelena it was an old
largely abandoned Winery when his father
Jim bought it in 1972 and he walked onto
the property and said oh man this is
this is Magic this is great it's a
state-of-the-art facility because and
Magic is what seemed to happen at shadow
model not long after take money for a
tasting something so magical it was made
into a movie Bottle Shock in 2008.
there's a movie Bottle Shock made a few
years ago now yeah Chris Pine Chris fine
yeah played this uh hippie looking guy
yeah that was you that was me
the movie tells the unlikely story of
how Shadow modeling's very first vintage
1973 Chardonnay won a blind taste test
in Paris
the Napa Valley
defeating world famous French wines and
shocking many wine experts here we have
inexperienced people in the wine
business nobody expected your wine they
did not these are the most experienced
tasters really in the world at that time
and they're the ones who you know
selected the California wines has been
you know good in wine history that taste
test is known as the Judgment of Paris
how did the Judgment of Paris change
things for shadow Montelena how did it
change things for Napa the immediate
instant change was we had had trouble
making any Headway with the established
wine markets except for California but
if you went to a wine broker in Boston
or New York or DC they'd say yeah no
California forget it the next day after
the peristasic could we get some of your
wife so yeah it changed not only for us
but for all in Napa Valley it all might
have happened much earlier had it not
been for prohibition when the sale of
alcohol was banned in America in 1920
early Napa wineries went out of business
prohibition just killed it that nothing
happened at all of California when
prohibition ended in 1933 wine
consumption grew only at a slow pace
until the late 60s but by 1972 that
curve started Rising steeply but in the
next 50 years be as successful as the
last 50. report came out this year
saying there's headwinds for the wine
industry young people aren't drinking as
much wine they order cocktails now when
they go out what I've seen in my 50
years of doing is that we're going to
get them in the long run everybody's
going to be 45 with three or four kids
at some time and you can't drink
cocktails after work or your doctor says
you got to knock off the Jack Daniels so
we're not too worried about people not
drinking wine
as this year's Harvest comes in and
grapes tumble into Crushers up and down
Napa Valley a class of 72. the winery
celebrating their 50th year are raising
a toast to themselves for CBS Saturday
morning John Blackstone Napa Valley
I was sort of hoping for a little silver
rose
Yeah I broke all morning I love a good
Silver Oak 1972 but did you see the year
2020 and how wine consumption went up
yeah they're going to get them
eventually what a shocker they are
we'll be right back
it's just us
you know it's not the same as it was
[Music]
I never saw a Bottle Shock I didn't
either actually I I want to see it now
yeah I really want to see it but you
know were you guys wine drinkers in your
20s that's what I was I I was to some
degree I like I started probably earlier
than a lot of people but I don't know
why I I I I I didn't drink at all in my
20s a friend of mine uh yeah I could
drink it all in my 20s sorry for another
time so yeah when did you start drinking
water uh my son he was born
my son was just he was a handful so I
needed like a little Hawaiian a little a
little wine to ease how about you
uh I said so I remember never seeing
wine around when I was growing up I
think because I was also partly when it
just wasn't as popular right yeah
America and then more and more so you
see it yeah in more places now as the
numbers have shown
um but yeah I had my my parents had some
phenomenal vintage of wine that they
were saving for this wonderful occasion
and I had friends send me a bottle of
wine somehow they got mixed up and I
ended up with this amazing I don't think
my mother's ever forgiven me for that
moment the
I I the other movie I was thinking of
sideways yeah that changed wine a lot
because I remember then you couldn't do
it you were never supposed to drink
Merlot and and for me it was A Walk in
the Clouds oh that was a beautiful
romantic